meine Tochter wird nie wieder da sein
natürlich wieder reinkommen und sagen
hey da bin ich der er tut 50 Jahre
unseres Lebens genommen mir genauso wie
man Ex-Freundin
Trauer bei Vater Marcel oh vor knapp
einem Jahr hat er seine Tochter mariell
durch einen Autounfall verloren
Auto saßen auch seine Freundin und deren
Tochter
beide schwer verletzt überleben aber den
Unfall seine Tochter Marielle war sofort
tot
der Angeklagte Christopher die ist mit
105 Stundenkilometern im
niedersächsischen Ort haben Büren
unterwegs als in einer Kreuzung den
Wagen von marcelohramt nur wenige
Augenblicke zuvor war Marcel oh noch mit
seiner Familie auf einem Schützenfest
haben sich fast zu essen geholt auf dem
Rückweg keine 250 m von dem Fest
entfernt stehen sie in einer Kreuzung
Marcel oh erinnert sich im Bild
Interview danach 50 100 Metern stand so
ein citybuster da waren zwei drei
betrunkene und der ganze Rest auf der
Straße fahre ran an die Linie bis zu dem
Moment wir haben kein Lichtschein gar
nichts gesehen überhaupt nicht
und das nicht so was ich weiß
ich habe nach links geguckt zwei Riesen
Scheinwerfer kamen auf mich zu ich habe
Scheiße geschrieben Moment
meine Frau also meine Ex Frau tut die
ich von Dir gehört habe
uns eingeschlagen das 20 Minuten bin ich
wieder um ca 20 Minuten bin ich wieder
aufgewacht ich habe mich dann im Auto
umgeschaut habe gesehen dass links also
rechts neben mir saß keiner mehr habe so
ist Füße auch nicht gesehen ich musste
meine Tochter sitzt hinter mir
ich war sofort tot
Leute berichten weiß ich das so
die Füße zwischen der Rückbank aus
geguckt habe bereits von einem Meter ab
68 Menschen waren so ein Stück
Kofferraum eingequetscht
[Musik]
er ist nicht gerade ausgefahren er ist
nicht rechts gefahren wie es jeder
normale Mensch tun würde er ist direkt
in unser Auto reingefahren wie jeder
Bericht jeder Bericht sagt für mich ist
das definitiv Mord
gerechte Strafe wird für ihn nicht geben
definitiv nicht und da sind wir uns alle
einig wir hoffen nur das merkt was
irgendwann Wasser für die Scheiße gebaut
hat
bei der Tote wird nie wieder da sein
[Musik]
natürlich wieder reinkommen und sagen
hey da bin ich
der hat uns 50 Jahre unseres Lebens
genommen mir genauso wie beim
Ex-Freundin
der Tod Raser Christopher dem muss sich
wegen fahrlässiger Tötung vor dem
Amtsgericht Celle verantworten
doch seine kleine Tochter bringt das
Urteil nicht zurück
[Musik]